from one tragedy in Texas to another one
this one in the Border City of
Brownsville at least eight people were
killed there and ten others hurt when an
SUV plowed into a group waiting near a
Migrant Center Police are investigating
whether this was intentional or not last
night a vigil was held for the victims
many of whom are believed to be Asylum
Seekers we have to warn you once again
the story also contains very disturbing
images Nicole skanga is in Brownsville
outside the Migrant Center with more on
this terrible story Nicole good morning
to you
Gail good morning we spoke to the
manager of this migrant shelter who told
us that most of the victims were
Venezuelan men enroute to their future
homes after a long and often difficult
Journey to the U.S they were just a bus
and a plane ticket away from starting
their life here in America
a bus stop turned into a gruesome scene
when a vehicle slammed into a crowd of
people we're pausing the video because
it's too graphic and disturbing to fully
show horrific it was terrible people
were running to help them the bodies
were all over the place the victims were
lined up along the road outside the
osnam homeless shelter when the SUV
struck them around 8 30 a.m Witnesses
say the driver then tried to flee but
was detained by others at the scene
there's reports that are going out that
he was driving reckless leaders others
saying that he was intoxicated and
there's others saying that he was
intentional seven people died at the
scene one died at a nearby hospital and
several others remain in critical
condition among the dead Angel ve
kavarka his cousin says he came across
the body seconds after the crash
authorities say those victims include
Asylum Seekers from Latin America the
Border community of Brownsville Texas is
in shock it's also been dealing with a
major increase in the number of migrants
Crossing into the city in the last week
of April border patrol says 15
000 crossed into Brownsville compared
with 1700 in the first two weeks of
April Mirna artiaga manages the osnan
shelter we have a lot of people from the
community coming to help us counsel
these people because they stay they're
traumatized
the driver who has not been identified
other than being a Hispanic male is in
custody at a local hospital police tell
us he is not cooperating but they've
ordered a toxicology report to determine
if he was under the influence Nate
Nicole thank you